normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I
don't think you're creating culture
you're creating counterculture then
that's that's what you're producing and
to Hannah's point it's not going to take
four years not an election it's a
generation when these genz have kids the
ones they don't abort right their kids
aren't going to want to follow what the
parents are doing kids kids want to have
counter thoughts to their parents
thoughts you you you can't immediately
assume that Jen Z is is leftist or
liberal I just saw poll today that gen Z
out of I I think all generations has the
more males who reject the uh identifying
as feminists so let me let me phrase it
there was a chart saying like uh genz
Millennial X and Boomers and gen Z males
are the least likely to claim they're
feminists so it's like you know and the
females are the most likely which is
they're angry at females because they're
not getting laid because the top 5% that
are attractive are the ones getting all
the swipes on twinder that's that's
that's what's going on and they're just
mad at females and they're rejecting it
I think the youngest generation is used
to being divided and I think they will
not stay that way as they become older
right as they age into their 20s 30s
things will change and right now we're
seeing a reckoning they are now turning
to the people who you know LED them here
right when we see everything that's
going on with Israel and Palestine and
go and and Hamas they are saying you
know we believe one thing but the
establishment believes believes another
thing do we even belong here anymore I
think a lot of them will shift more
independent I don't think it'll be a
perfect uh you know just they all March
right over and register as Republicans
but I think generally they are used to
being divided and so therefore they
won't mind being unaffiliated and I I
got to stop you there I think you're
completely wrong they don't hate women
they they aren't mad they're not getting
laid they're angry that feminism has
created a world in which women are going
on only fans and not seeking
relationships and these are guys many of
these men are just like look I just want
to have like a wife and have have a
family and there are many women saying
the exact same thing but women are
feeling pressured like they have to go
and work and men are struggling to
compete in this hyp sexualized hookup
culture Marketplace so you're getting
young guys who are just like this is
effed this does not work women of course
I think the reason why gen Z females are
the most likely to say they're feminists
they have to it's it's peer pressure
it's social pressure that women are more
susceptible to social pressure than men
are so the guys are just like get out of
here with that stuff I can't stand it
and what do they want guys probably just
want to get married I mean look there
are there are there are many guys who
just want to get laid that's true but I
think the average guy just wants to get
like married yeah I I think that's fair
and I think there is intense social
pressure I mean I felt this way when I
was you know in public high school doing
whatever and they were like well if
you're a woman you have to be a feminist
you have to be a feminist you have to be
a feminist and you know every
generation that is surveyable right now
this a few research study the majority
of all age groups identify as feminists
but yet women aren't happy and Hope so
we know I mean there's a reason that
Jezebel shuddered today right like the
feminist publication couldn't survive
yet we have Eevee magazine on the rise I
mean there is a desire well explain
explain Eevee so Eevee is um I I just no
as an alternative women's magazine they
particularly pay attention to more
traditional values and they promote
femininity over feminism and I love the
work that they do U and I think that
they are you know one of the reasons I
got into them that they just interested
in you know classical Beauty they're not
trying to make you cut all your hair off
and dress dress Ambiguously they're just
saying you should like being woman and
that's cool and I think there are lots
of young women who are looking for that
for and the thing is women skew towards
wanting you know emotional and social
acceptance and it that can be a strength
I don't mean to like downplay it at all
but that means if all the women around
you say I'm a feminist and men are bad
then you are likely to also think maybe
that's the way and we have new Outlets
coming out that are offering them an
alternative so even though the majority
of young women today gen z may say
they're feminist right now I wonder if
that will change and you'll get the
stories that are like I regret
identifying as feminist my mom raised me
my my intense feminist mother raised me
and she was wrong I love her but this
was not the right past because
ultimately the genders aren't supposed
to be enemies they're supposed to be
partners a lot of it's going to be too
late though a lot of these girls who are
only fans who are doing these things
they're it's going to be too late for
them men men don't want that men do not
want that it's crazy every we see more
and more stories about women being I I
quit my job and I did only fans and wow
I made so much money and it's just like
wow that's poison absolute poison but
this is what modern leftist and feminism
promotes the sex positive culture and it
is really fascinating that what are we
getting women's sports are slowly you
know males are competing in women's
sports and women are quitting their
careers like as doctors nurses police
officers as professional fighters to do
porn mhmh they're the most sexually
objectified they have ever been and this
is what feminism is saying like good
this is what we wanted unless a man does
it then it's bad except also who's
paying for your only fans men are
clicking men are paying that's right I
know a lot of women who you know adapted
those feminist qualities throughout High
School never got married and now they're
my age I'm 38 and they still act like
they're in high school you know or
college so it's a lot of dude this is
what this is what I've been saying about
Millennials uh why I lo the millennial
generation they they have this mentality
that you can't be a boss this is
communism okay and this is a component
of Communism and I think it comes from
college I think it comes from not it's
not it's not its root College it's what
college has become you've got a kid he
grows up from 0 to 5 does nothing at 5
years old he begins kindergarten maybe
there's preschool there and daycare and
stuff and little bits here and there but
mostly nothing 5 years old to what 13
you've got grade school they're told
what to do then High school they're told
what to do then College they're told
what to do they graduate at 22 and they
say what should I do now the government
comes around and says we'll tell you
what to do this is why I think we we
don't see very many Millennial
politicians it's why we don't see uh uh
we're not it's why you you get all these
Millennials complaining about Boomers
have all the wealth they they're holding
the wealth and I'm like it's because
Millennials aren't doing anything and I
think the reason is Millennials have
this mental block where they think
they're not good enough and someone else
is in charge so this is and that's
exemplified by looking at a a
presidential election with a bunch of
octogenarians or SE genarian why is
everybody so old don't get me wrong
Ronda Sanz is up there okay VI of course
is up there but it's few and far between
and again Boomer's control the wealth
why Millennials keep saying the Boomer
is my boss instead of saying I'm going
to be my own boss and start a business
then they go but it's so hard to get
money it's so hard to do ask any of
these people how they started their
business they started from nothing M
look at at the business we're building
here we started with nothing quite
literally like I got a job I saved up
money I got a better job I saved up
money and then I started my Independent
Business practice and slowly built up to
this point there's no secret it's
sacrifice you know grind through the mud
and the dirt work your fingers to the
Bone and build it up I think you also
have to be willing to accept
responsibility though and I think that's
what a lot of Millennials don't want
they have this desire to stay childish
in so many ways and that keeps them from
you know all good things a little bit of
risk right so if you really want to be
in Char run your own business you have
to accept that that will come with some
responsibility you may have to be you
know responsible for proving your own
health insurance or whatever it is or
you don't get that and they would
ultimately rather have someone to blame
you know I think when I if I'm watching
someone play a video game and they're
bad at it I get really frustrated and
I'm just like can I give me the
controller like dude you you're not
jumping right let me do it and then I'll
be like watch never watch me play a
video game I
I'm like leave I'll play I'll do my
thing I I struggle with watching other
people try to solve problems that I feel
like I could solve faster and better and
call me arrogant call me cocky call me
call me whatever you want that is the
mentality that leads me to to look my
40-year-old boss in the eye when I'm 16
and say you're a I could do your
job better than you I quit and I leave
I'm not kidding when I was 16 I was
working at a fast food restaurant and I
I guarantee you I could have done a
better job than the manager they hired
why because I had experience doing man
managerial work at my family's Cafe when
I was 12 so I'm like I saw my mom do all
this stuff she taught me some of it then
I see a guy who gets hired has zero
experience but you know he was an
assistant manager you know at a
different shop so when he comes in here
he doesn't understand how anything Works
everything's kind of getting jammed up
everything's bad like time scheduling is
bad and I'm like bro I've been here
longer than you I know how this works
better than you they hired you for
arbitrary reasons so I said I ain't
doing this I'm out I'm going to do my
own thing what do I do I've done a bunch
of things in my life life to make money
one day I'm like I need to pay my rent
so I took my guitar and I went down and
I played in the subway in Chicago and
then I got yelled at and said you need a
permit so I went I went downtown paid
the five bucks got the permit went back
got into a fight with some guy who was
dancing with the football because he's
like this is my spot and I'm like okay
and I would make probably 15 bucks an
hour just playing guitar I'd play for
two or three hours top 40s I'd make like
45 bucks and then I'd go put in the bank
and then I'd be done like that was so
much fun I'm just jamming playing the
guitar then I figured something out I
went to Wrigley baseball field right as
a game was ending I made $200 in one
hour cuz everybody's wasted and I was
like wow why would I get a job and all
my friends were like I'm broke I need a
job and I'm like look man I'll be honest
I've had jobs right I went and worked at
a bar it was hard to find jobs I worked
at the airport for a couple years and
then it was actually after the airport I
decided I'm going to go just play guitar
in the street and make money and then
eventually I got bored and worked for
nonprofit stuff like that but ultimately
it always comes down to what I see today
is people who
say it's it's either the get out of my
way and let me do it or I ain't touching
that that's your problem I think you're
explaining a solution-minded um a
solution oriented mindset right a lot of
kids don't learn how to fail because we
just do it for them in a lot of
Millennials they weren't allowed to fail
they got all their trophies they were
just pushed through grades and they
never had to figure out how to find a
solution to get better at something my
kids I love when they fail it is the
most exciting thing that I see from them
because they only get to talk about
finding Solutions yeah well how did you
fail at this thing what thing did you do
wrong what could you try differently
next time and my kids they find
solutions they they fail a couple of
times and they get better at it I wish
that wasn't rare but I do the same with
my kids and you they you got to let them
fail you know that's that's the big
lesson I think the system we're in
infantilizes young men and women and so
they're risk averse like you were saying
earlier and you know you can see that
even in Little Things la oh and super
lazy but like even little things like
they they're afraid to pick pick up the
phone you know cuz they're afraid of
even answering and talking to a real
person you know that's crazy I recorded
a segment today which is going coming
out tomorrow on my uh Tim news channel
of this woke woman getting pulled over
for a DUI she's driving the wrong way
down the road she smells like alcohol
she gets pulled over and she admits to
having several drinks and the cop is so
nice and she's like I'm nonbinary and
he's like okay man I'm sorry I okay I'll
I'll try my best and then he's like can
you walk in a straight line for me and
she's like no because I have mental
health issues and like generational
trauma because and then when he finally
decide there's one point where he's like
follow my finger no ma'am follow my
finger I'm trying but you're trying to
intimidate me and he's like I don't know
how I'm doing that then when he finally
decides to arrest her she's like dude
you're you're being a white man and it
this is this is what's going on in their
brains she was driving the wrong way
down the road into oncoming traffic
after having several drinks I don't want
to say she's drunk I don't know she had
three drinks maybe and so she gets
pulled over for it MH get out of the car
and she's like I don't want to get out
of my car I goes we're pass that now out
of the car you know St by she's like
okay and then she said you're being a
white man what think about the mental
perspective she must have on driving
drunk the wrong way down the road and
it's the fault of the officer for being
a white man did she go to Evergreen
College where Brett Weinstein was
remember like they were yelling at the
at the guy for being like the hand
movements are aggressive you know put
them down but they were lying that
because after he stopped they all
laughed at him oh yeah no they were they
were using that against him for sure did
he identify himself as a white male how
did how did she know that's right no she
just used it like a slur which is also
telling right what if she had said like
oh you're acting like a Korean man like
would that mean something different no
it's only to insult him as a white man
one of the funniest things is she goes I
have really bad social anxiety and then
he goes you and me both and then she
goes okay like uhoh your stupid lie and
excuse and victimization didn't work on
this guy she tried every card in the
book and then she got arrested but this
is the generation that gets created it
is not all Millennials obviously you
know I'm a millennial I don't know how
old are you 38 we're all Millennials
look at us sitting here oh those dang
Millennials they ruined Millennial
millennialism they ruined the generation
yeah I had a grandfather I think it made
a big difference yeah I think
grandfathers are like the uh they're The
Gatekeepers of the old ways and most of
our generation can't even find their
fathers totally that's so sad a lot of
time with your grandfather sorry I did
actually he was he my hero this man uh
couple of motorcycle accidents um last
one he rolled 15 times he had multiple
skin grab surgery eye hanging out of his
face you know they told him you have
brain damage you're never going to exist
the way you did this man went back to
school and got a PhD and he got several
of letters that certifications find his
name spent the rest of his life helping
drug addicts alcoholics this man is my
hero my grandpa once uh I may have told
a story I I made a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich when I was staying with
him when I was 18 and he was he was
going to give me a ride somewhere and
then he's like come on let's get out of
here and then I I looked down at the
sandwich I was like throw it away he's
like what's wrong with it and I was like
it's got mold on it he walks over grabs
it shoves it in his mouth and he goes do
you have any idea what we ate during the
Depression let's go that my grandpa
exactly I was going to say like it's so
important to talk to the older people in
your life and if you have a grandfather
grandma like I I interviewed mine for
hours before he passed away for years
you know I have multiple hours of
interviews with him because I could
learn about you learn about so much time
before you hear at War you know he was a
cop in in New York City in the 70s when
it was all on fire then he was a hearse
driver so kind of like ran the gamut of
like death war life you know marriage
and all these things and a lot of people
don't have that access to someone who's
well and also you have to Foster family
relationships right like I my parents
were older when they had kids anyways
but also my parents were IM immigrants
to the us so we didn't see our
grandparents that often and I think
about now you know technology is so
Advanced where like your kids
grandparents could call them on the
phone they could have access and it's
like we don't appreciate what we have in
that in that connection because we're so
busy saying the older generation did
this and you know I'm I'm here to blame
the Boomers for all kinds of stuff too
but also they were your parents you
should get to know them and I think part
of growing up is accepting that your
parents are humans and have faults and
have failed and so many people aren't
ready to do that even though they are at
an age where they could become parents
and learning from their mistakes kind of
like how you watch your kids learn from
their mistakes right because they got a
ton of they can tell you about too I
still have dinner with my grandma once
or twice a month we being all the kids
over cuz important this is why I hate
Rah emanuel's brother I forget his name
but he wrote that article I think it
might have been in Time Magazine Jim
Emanuel maybe I don't know I don't I
forget but he wrote the thing about how
old people should let let themselves die
and we shouldn't have we should have a
society without old people and I'm as
I'm reading that article my kid was
downstairs yeah with his great grandma
learning about history the same way I
did you know from the same woman you
know from from her perspective and I was
like this is just straight up evil but
they don't want you to have family I
mean the nuclear family like the mom dad
children relationship is really
important but the extended family is a
gift into itself and if you have a
strong extended family with good values
who can support each other then you are
less reliant on the government enemies
which is exactly what they don't want
exactly they want to destroy the family
and it goes back to in INF infantilizing
everybody so that when you are 2122 the
government steps in Mommy Dad there are
certain countries I think Iceland is one
of them that will give grandparents tax
breaks or some kind of you know income
or whatever if they are going to instead
of you know enrolling the kid in daycare
state sponsored School whatever if they
stay with grandparents and the
grandparents are the ones who take care
of them while the parents are working or
doing whatever that means that like
instead of a stranger your parents who
potentially you have a good relationship
with would be spending time with your
children in an environment that tends to
your child's specific needs because they
love and care about them like that's a
great system now here's the challenge we
all recognize this issue because we were
raised well and there are other people
who don't care at all because they were
not mhm you can't go to one of these
Millennials and be like listen it's very
important and here's why cuz they're
going to say you're nuts I don't care
where's the sex party at and then when
they're when they're oh man I am not
looking forward to aging Millennials
right one of the one of the debate
questions about raising the age of
retirement and Social Security it is
going to be wild when you have a whole
bunch of single isolated childless
individuals like just demanding the
government pay their bills for them what
what what what is the marketplace going
to look like the government's going to
give you a 3D printed suicide pods I
think you know what I I I I would not be
surprised just got an erection after
hearing that yeah that's that's why maid
is emerging most likely seriously I
would not be surprised if the younger
Generations forcefully enact some kind
of homing for aging Millennials and I'll
tell you why right now the market for
you know uh look Millennials are in
their 30s it's like it's like early 30s
maybe late 20s but mostly early 30s to
late 30s these are people who can still
run and jump and somersault and backflip
and eat pizza but oh man once you're
getting around 37 38 you got to cut the
salt down you got to be careful what
you're eating you got to start
stretching more in these things imagine
what's going to be like when they're 50
and 60 and they can't do any of these
things but they're still single and
childless what will they do we are going
to have a wave of stories about a
strange stench coming from an apartment
building MH it is not these these happen
periodically it's like neighbors notice
a strange smell and found Ed had passed
away several days earlier happened down
the road for me in my hometown it is
going to be it is going to be nuts and
there's I I would not be surprised if a
laog gets passed where it's like
checkups have to be performed on anybody
over the age of 65 because of how many
dead bodies are being found isolated in
their homes I'll tell you what's scary a
scary thought is that you could be 25
years old take a shower in the morning
in your one bedroom apartment you're
single you got work and you step out of
the bathtub and you slip and you hit
your head on the on the sink and you're
dead and no one knows and then a week
goes by and they're like damn at 25 now
it's rare right it gets increasingly
more likely when you get older and you
start falling and you're out of shape
it's going to be nuts when we have like
I mean it's going to be tens of millions
more Millennials who are single and
childless in their 60s living in studios
it's going to it's going to be
absolutely nuts they're going to so and
and if there's no family member to put
them in a home what happens Mass elderly
homelessness of millennials mhm and then
I so one of the things that may happen
is they're going to vote for weird crazy
communist garbage and that may start
that that will absolutely extract from
the younger generation already Social
Security is insolvent the older
generation is getting paid and the
younger generation's paying for it but
we're not having kids so population's
going to decline then Social Security
won't be maintained and Millennials are
going to be old and they're going to say
no I paid I get my fair share and the
generation is going to be like we can
run faster than you we're going to send
in the law enforcement to bring you to
homes and that's that's going to be your
Ware what scares me also is the amount
of ssris those depressed people are
going to be taking and how many more
people are going to be on these pills
and how crazy they're going to get you
know after all that depression up to the
meterse exactly I going to say this is
why they are trying so hard to make the
neuralink in the metaverse so then they
can just strap you in the Pod sink the
Pod into the ground lock it up and then
you're in The Matrix and it doubles as
the suicide pod I looked at the think
it's like 30 or 40% SSRI intake across
the past 10 years 30 or 40% it's a
ridiculous number yeah it's insane it's
insane it's really scary and there's not
like most people who take ssris are just
on them forever which I don't want to be
you know too General about it there are
people who really benefit from it but
they aren't saying have you considered
through your lifestyle changing your
lifestyle have you consider changing
your diet have you considered you know
exercising more have you thought about
you know stop hanging out with all these
people that make you miserable instead
it's just sort of like continue to pay
for therapy and ssris indefinitely
forever G me a pill why is it not
working mean can't keep living immorally
but it won't be a pill eventually it'll
be a plug it'll be I think it'll be like
a uh you know how you know how the uh
Apple laptop chargers work they're
magnets and it just clicks in it doesn't
actually like interlock it just snaps
that's what it's going to be for the
neuralink there's going to be thin
copper cables that go into your uh I
think that's what they're doing it goes
into your like sarabellum or whatever
and uh you'll have like a little metal
pad and you'll just take a little magnet
thing it go it'll stick right to it and
then
well elon's looking for people right now
if they want to sign up to volunteer
because FDA has approved human trials
where the robot he built will cut open
your skull and thread the implant into
your brain go for that Co this is for
this is for people who are blind deaf
paralyzed I'm totally fine with that
yeah but the problem is we know where it
goes exactly and you're going to have
some 60-year-old Millennial woman being
like I just don't have any friends
anymore and I'm so ladly and they're
going to be like would you like to be 20
again and go partying back on the north
side of Chicago Chago plug on in baby
and sit in the PO and we'll pump you
full of bugs I would choose a different
thing I would be like the head of the
doj and
go the M you choose to live in the
reality where you get Justice and you
you're locked in the PO of everyone on
the Island's getting
arrested that's the thing though we have
like one of the the the battles for
making to like reinvesting in culture
and reinvigorating culture is to make it
so that life outside the Pod is better
and worthy even when things are hard it
is more desirable to be there because I
think about you know you know if you can
go into the pot I guess you could see
all your loved ones whatever else but
they're not real like you have to want
the reality enough even with the bad
parts of it and I think we have gener we
have Generations that are being trained
to numb themselves and avoid things
always which makes the neural link sort
of an inevitable reality because it's
the ultimate numbing it takes you out of
who you are coid lockdowns accelerated
like the divorce between people who hate
reality like nature right and you saw a
lot of people stay in their homes I know
people who had young kids who did not
leave their home for 5 to 6 months right
and they could get their groceries
delivered they could be safe somehow
they still got coid in the apartments
that's another story but like their
their identities meant more to them
online so their digital identities took
over their physical identities which is
why metaverse is going to take over
which is why it's hilarious the other
day when we're sharing that image of
that person who had their Avatar as the
girl but Sydney whatever the name was
right but in real life it's just a trans
person who's like a 50-year-old dude
right with a ponytail we've talked about
it's the movie surrogates you've seen it
no yeah uh it's a world where everyone
sits in a pod and they have a robot
version of themselves go out and work
it's safer and there's like this hot
chick making out the guy some there's an
accident that happens and so they try
and track down the owner of the of the
surrogate and they find a 500lb morbidly
obese man in a pod also dead cuz some
crazy thing happened but the point is
they were like oh that hot chick you're
making out with 500 PB morbidly obese
man that's like only fans right now and
there's guys messaging women who who's
the messages are coming from dudes and
like wherever they're from you know
Idaho yo the crazy thing is people don't
care on Instagram you have a whole bunch
of AI generated accounts and they say
they are and it's crazy people are
commenting like you're so beautiful I'm
like it says AI generated person they
don't care they don't care but there's
no risk telling AI you're beautiful
right there's no risk in doing that it's
not actually going out and having to
meet a girl and say hey I think you're
pretty and I'd love to take you to
dinner look have you ever played a video
game with cheat codes Game Genie it gets
boring yeah so so what happens is
typically the way you do it is you play
the game you beat it once you're done
then you play with cheat codes for fun
to explore the game but after a while
you're like I can do whatever I want
whatever I want I'm I'm over it I'm
bored this is what metaverse is going to
be like if unless people choose to enter
simulated realities with rules and
limits otherwise they'll get bored real
quick which is the end goal of Communism
to make people uh feel like they're the
god it's a false like reality of them
being the god whereas obviously though
that's not the case because the god
becomes the government and then they
destroy you but they want to make you
pretend that you're in charge and have
agency it makes me feel like we're on
the cusp of a lot of people w up to this
I mean I I I I'm a girl so I like a lot
of relationship podcasts and a lot of
them you'll have girls calling in
talking about breakups and being like he
was just really controlling he wanted to
control me and it's like yes because
ultimately that is the same guy who will
pick to be in the neural link so that he
can control the entire environment
around him like we're all headed the
same direction thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time